nicht konkurrenz sondern humor und
kreativität statt vokabeltests darum
geht es bei der internationalen
deutschen pr
hier werden gerade vier der besten
deutsch schüler der welt getestet
mit dabei die 18 jährige tschechin
katerina 100 schüler aus 47 ländern
treten bei der olympiade in drei
niveaustufen an eine der wettbewerbs
disziplinen einer wandzeitung basteln
und im team präsentieren
die deutsche sprache ist dabei nicht die
einzige herausforderung
im mittelpunkt steht auf die
interkulturelle zusammenarbeit
13 tage verbringen die teilnehmer in
frankfurt am main hatte gina martin
schofer ist zum ersten mal auch zum
ersten mal in deutschland und begegnen
jetzt den menschen deren sprache sie
bereits gelernt haben
der deutsche charakter
dass sich hinter und also dass die
geschichte der pünktlich sein und alles
in einen kampf um das gibt mir sehr
aufwand einfach das sehr präzis pcs sein
wollen wie hier in rumänien mussten sich
alle teilnehmer in nationalen
vorentscheiden für die sprache olympiade
qualifiziert
nur zwei schüler pro land kommen ins
finale in frankfurt am main
repräsentieren die schüler auch ihre
heimatländer wie beim jahrmarkt der
kulturen am flughafen gegenseitigen
akzeptieren mit toleranz das alles mit
für uns eine rolle
wir wollen noch handlungsorientiert die
ganzen sachen durchführen die schüler
sollen dabei auch was lernen sollen
spiel spaß haben auch dabei deshalb geht
es nicht nur um den wettbewerb sondern
auch darum in die deutsche kultur
einzutauchen
so wie bei einem exklusiv konzert mit
der deutschen rockband revolverheld
die band ist offizieller botschafter der
deutsch olympiade mit deutschen texten
bist du ja eigentlich regional sehr
beschränkt und spielt in den
deutschsprachigen ländern
jetzt kommen hier 50 nationalitäten nach
frankfurt und wir sind dann die deutsche
band die die deutsche sprache
repräsentiert ist natürlich eine große
ehre und wir freuen uns sehr dass wir
teil dieser deutsch olympiade sein
können dann der offizielle höhepunkt die
preisverleihung
den gewinnern winken sprachkurse und
praktika bei deutschen unternehmen
könnte die überraschung für katharina
martin schofer wohl nicht sein
sie hole platz eins in ihren
sprachlichen und damit ist klar
bereits im nächsten jahr heißt es für
die tschechen wieder auf nach
deutschland